all right listen up a missouri business
owner is getting creative after she was
shut down for refusing to enforce mass
mandates amanda wallace the owner of
ray's cafe reopening her restaurant as a
private club to avoid the strict covert
protocols put on restaurants in that
state and now the county is still
attempting to shut the business down via
a court order amanda wallace joins us
now amanda what brought you to this
point
um
just to keep my business open brought me
to this point just to keep functioning
so in order to avoid uh the mass mandate
you have 90 percent of your staff
vaccinated uh you said what you said
what were you gonna do
we were completely complying at that
point and she i still got shut down so
we turned into a private club and we're
not open to the public
so now you charge a membership fee
yeah a dollar membership fee a dollar
membership so i become a member do i get
a card
uh you will get a card you just sign in
pay your dollar and
you're in the club and therefore you
avoid what the county is trying to do
correct correct so where are you where
do you stand right now
um
i'm just waiting honestly i i don't know
where i stand i'm waiting but do you
have lunch for example you're serving
lunch today you serve breakfast you
yes we're open eight to two
um
well i i i admire you're being creative
here's what the county said of jackson
despite numerous warnings and attempts
by the county to work with the business
owner she has refused to take corrective
action has made it clear that she has no
plans to do so that is why for the first
time during the pandemic the county will
be seeking a court order to close the
business what's your reaction
this happened within one week start to
finish the fines the tickets
that's ridiculous over a mask
that's not
a mandate is not a law this should not
be happening
and
your customers know the risk they're
vaccinated they're not vaccinated they
don't you don't want to ask them they
don't tell you the customer's
complaining
no not at all the customers have had
nothing but
support and love and
it's been amazing has you a lawyer
consulted you to go private like this
i do have legal assistance yes
and do you believe you're legally
protected
yes
nice amanda i hope you win i really i
know how hard it is to get a restaurant
going raise cafe check it out become a
member for a dollar
go get em amanda meanwhile you